okay so today's video will be the
evidence that supports the theory of
evolution so let's get started well so
let's go ahead and start with arguably
the most compelling evidence to support
evolution and that's the fossil record
the collection of all known fossils and
most of them like you see in the picture
here are buried and rock and to be
specific they're buried and what is
called sedimentary rock you know here's
a fish buried in sedimentary rock here
is an unfitting here are footprints or
tracks left behind in sedimentary rock
well this this is exactly what it looks
like here's fossilized feces that were
uncovered in sedimentary rock well
despite most fossils being found in
sedimentary rock you know there are some
that are found in other means you know
for instance here's an insect that was
trapped in tree sap and the tree sap
hardened it into what we call amber you
know they've been fossils that have been
found frozen with an ice really really
well preserved until you know we come
along and discover them but most found
in sedimentary rocks so let's talk about
that next so let's talk about
sedimentary rock you know over time
wind and rain will carry dirt and soil
and this is called sediment and over
time the dirt and soil begins to
accumulate into a layer that will
eventually harden into what's called
sedimentary rock well this process
repeats over and over and over more wind
and rain will carry dirt and soil and
another layer here we have a third layer
of sedimentary rock forming and over
time this will harden and again as time
passes the process continues more dirt
and soil accumulates more sediment
accumulates and eventually hardens into
sedimentary rock and so you know let me
add a fifth layer just for fun and let
me add a sixth layer here just for fun I
hope you get the idea but here we have
various layers of sedimentary rock Iraq
do rock layers actually look like this
yes here you see a picture taken you can
actually see the various levels and
layers of the sedimentary rock and
within these rock layers could be
fossils that were buried you know
millions of years ago waiting to be
uncovered
and so we can determine the relative age
of a fossil or you excuse me of a fossil
or a rock layer based on its depth how
deep it's buried what rock layer it's
buried within so let me ask you which of
these six rock layers do you think is
the oldest well based on how what we
talked about how sedimentary rock forms
I hope you would say the oldest is the
lowest layer therefore that top layer is
the youngest and this is really
supported by the law of superposition
new rock layers form on top of older
rock layers and if I add some fossils
here let's pretend that these animals
died and their dead remains were buried
and eventually uncovered by people well
if I were to ask you which of these
fossils is the oldest well because the
trilobite is buried in the lowest layer
of sedimentary rock it would be the
oldest as well if I reset the picture
and ask you why aren't dinosaur fossils
found in the deepest rock layers you can
see the dinosaur fossil found in the
third layer from the top well the reason
you don't see any dinosaur fossils in
the three lower levels is probably
dinosaurs did not exist at the time when
the three lower levels were forming and
how about this and what does it mean if
trilobite fossils no longer appear in
the upper rock layers
well eventually life may go extinct and
if you have the trial abite fossils
found in layer one two and three and all
of a sudden they no long
appear they're probably extinct and
that's why there's none left to leave
behind a fossil and so when we examine
the fossil record we can come to a few
conclusions if we you know here we have
again some trilobite fossils in one of
the lower levels a little higher maybe
fish fossils a little higher maybe
dinosaur fossils a little higher let's
say the fossils of large mammals
you know this pattern demonstrates
nicely one of the conclusions and that's
newer fossils tend to be more complex we
don't find large mammal fossils deep
deep deep within the layers of the earth
where we would find trilobite fossils so
that's simply because large mammals
didn't exist large mammals don't appear
in the fossil record until really the
extinction of the dinosaurs another
conclusion that we can come from is seen
nicely in this picture here we can
compare the relationships between modern
organisms such as modern-day horses to
the fossilized remains of horses that we
found long ago and what we've seen is
over the past 40 or 50 million years or
so
horses have gradually become larger in
size no coincidence this is also around
the time when the dinosaurs went extinct
that mammals began to grow and evolve
into a large larger organisms that we
see today but we can compare fossils
from ages ago to those horses that are
still alive today too to see that life
really has a common ancestry up a
connection in its evolutionary past
let's take a moment to talk about how we
can determine the absolute age of a
fossil through what's called radiometric
dating you know we can determine the
relative age of a fossil based on the
layer of sedimentary rock that a file so
might be found in but radiometric dating
allows us to determine a more accurate
or an absolute age of a fossil and it
uses isotopes atoms of the same element
with differing neutrons probably the
best-known examples of this would be
carbon-12 and carbon-14 if you've ever
heard of ever heard of carbon dating
well this is an example of radiometric
dating first of all let's look at the
carbon on the top here it has atomic
number of six which means six protons it
has the atomic mass of 12 which means
six protons plus how many neutrons adds
up to 12 well that would be six so
carbon 12 has a combination of six
protons and six neutrons look at the
carbon on the bottom it has the atomic
number of six which means six protons
well it's mass is 14 so six protons plus
how many neutrons adds up to 14 well
that would be eight and so carbon 14 has
six protons but eight neutrons and you
can see that's the definition of an
isotope atoms of the same element
they're both carbon but they have a
different number of neutrons well what's
my point where am I going with this
well when organisms are alive organisms
are breathing in gases from the
atmosphere organisms are drinking
organisms are eating and when we take in
molecules through breathing through
drinking through eating we are taking in
carbon 12 and also carbon 14 so when an
organism is alive it's constantly taking
these two atoms in these two isotopes in
but when an organism dies its carbon-14
begins to break down or decay and so
carbon-14 has what we call a half-life
of 5730 years well what this means the
half-light half-life the definition is
the number of years it takes for half of
the isotope to decay so for example
after five thousand seven hundred and
thirty years half or 50% of the
carbon-14 that was in an organism when
it died will have will be gone it will
have decayed don't go over an example of
this in a moment but what we can do is
we can use the ratio of carbon-12 to
carbon-14 to help determine the absolute
age of a fossil let's go over a couple
examples of this here we have our three
fossils again and let's pretend the
atmosphere of Earth naturally has 40,000
parts per million of carbon 14 well just
as a reminder the half-life of carbon-14
is 5730 years let's pretend that the
fish fossil is discovered and analyzed
and it contains 20,000 parts per million
of carbon 14
notice how 20,000 is half of 40,000 when
the fish was alive it likely would have
had 40,000 parts per million because it
was taken in molecules from the
environment but now it only has 20,000
parts per million that means one
half-life of time has passed and it's
lost 50% of its carbon-14 we would
determine this fish fossil to be about
5730 years old but look at the insect
let's pretend the insect contains 10,000
parts per million of carbon 14
well 10,000 is half of 20,000 and 20,000
is half of 40,000 so two half-lives of
time has passed since this inside
was alive so two times 5730 years would
be eleven thousand four hundred and
sixty years that is what we would
determine this insect fossil to be look
at the trial a bite on the bottom let's
pretend it has five thousand parts per
million of carbon 14 well five thousand
is half of ten thousand and ten thousand
as half of twenty thousand and twenty
thousand is half of forty thousand so
three half-lives of time has passed so
three times five thousand seven hundred
and thirty will give you the absolute
age of the trial a bite seventeen
thousand one hundred and ninety years
old so that's a good example of how we
use isotopes to determine the absolute
age of various fossils and when we use
radiometric dating and other methods of
dating rocks and fossils we can come up
with numbers such as the earth is
four-and-a-half billion years old
prokaryotes or bacteria are three and a
half billion years old fish the first
vertebrates on earth about five hundred
and ten million years old here's the
date for amphibians reptiles mammals and
dinosaurs birds and flowering plants and
humans about two hundred thousand years
old well you know these numbers are
accurate however there's a problem can
anyone really relate to these ages you
know the average human may live 7080
years at best so it's really really hard
for a human to grasp what it means to be
five hundred and ten million years old
so here's a neat little trick that I'm
gonna go through here okay so what we're
gonna do here in this little scale here
we're gonna condense the four and a half
billion years that Earth has existed
into a single 24-hour day because that's
something that we all can relate to so
on the far left would be Earth's
formation on the far right would be
present day at this scale one minute is
a quote as equivalent to three million
years well let's get started on this
so when we start to add some information
well here's a picture of what are called
stromatolites and these are rock
formations created by bacteria and
stromatolites are the oldest evidence of
life on Earth and they date back to
about three and a half billion years old
on our timeline that puts us around 4:30
in the morning well the next thing I
want to add is the first vertebrates
fish the first animals with a backbone
fossil evidence indicates that they
evolved around five hundred and ten
million years ago that puts us after
9:00 p.m. at night I also want to
mention that fish are interesting not
just because they're the first
vertebrates but hey humans are
vertebrates so we have an ancestor long
ago with fish well the next one I want
to mention are in amphibians and FIB
Ian's are interesting because they were
the first vertebrates that could walk on
land yes they use the water to reproduce
but they're able to you know they're
hybrids they're able to go between the
land and water and fossils put them on
earth about 340 million years ago right
around 10:00 p.m. on our 24-hour time
line well the next I want to mention are
the reptiles what's unique about the
reptiles is they were the first
vertebrates to live exclusively on land
fossils indicate that they evolved
around 310 million years ago that puts
them around about 10:30 p.m. at night
the next I want to mention are the
mammals and the dinosaurs and mammals
are interesting of course because humans
are mammals so the evolution of mammals
eventually leads to humans well mammals
and dinosaurs evidence shows the both
evolved around the same time about 250
million years ago on our scale here that
puts them around you know about 10:45 at
night the next I want to include here
would be flowering plants in bird
it kind of makes sense that they evolve
around the same time because again birds
often pollinate flowers well this was
about a hundred and seventy five million
years ago on our 24-hour timeline that
puts them just after 11 p.m.
well let's add this let's add Homo
sapiens us humans fossils indicate that
humans evolved around 150 200,000 years
ago look at our scale one minute is
equivalent to three million years were
not even a minute old on this scale in
fact we're about three or four seconds
old on this timeline and when you look
at the pattern there's a really obvious
conclusion life began very simple but
has become gradually more complex over
the years well so let's talk about
fossils a little more you know there are
what are called transitional fossils
fossils that link to different types of
life you know here's a great example of
one for a long time scientist I
anticipated to birds well if that's true
shouldn't there be some fossils out
there that are part reptile and part
bird some transitional fossils and this
picture shows a transitional fossil
called Archaeopteryx an organism that
shares both bird and reptile
characteristics well in the fossil
picture you can see some of its reptile
features you can see the bony tail upon
closer examination it has teeth well
what about the bird features well it has
wings and it has feathers and it has a
wishbone and so here we have a good
example of a fossil with characteristics
of two different types of organisms
birds and reptiles you know for a long
time scientists have believed that some
kind of land mammal eventually led to
the evolution of whales well if that's
true shouldn't there be something out
there some fossils out there that's part
land
and partway land and here's a great
example of that basilosaurus it shares
both whale and land mammal features well
the land features would be the fact that
it has teeth more similar to a wolf and
it has hind limbs you know actual leg
bones but when it comes to the whale
features the ears are the bones of a
whale and as a long spine like a whale
and we found it we find these fossils in
dried-up ocean beds so we know it was a
it was an aquatic organism you know
another example for a long time
scientists have believed that fish
eventually evolved into amphibians well
that's true shouldn't they be out there
something out there that's part fish in
part and phibian well here's a great
example called Tiktaalik it's a fossil
the fossil remains of an organism that's
part fish and part amphibian well what's
so fish about it is you can see the
scales on its back and it has fins but
what's so amphibian about it is that it
has eyes on the top of its head like an
amphibian and it has little wrists like
an amphibian and so when you examine
these transitional fossils it it really
nicely demonstrates that for instance
birds and reptiles have a common
ancestor so these are great specimens
here that show that life is evolved over
the years well the next topic I want to
mention are what are called vestigial
structures these are organs or body
parts which have lost most or all of
their original function or their a
function is greatly reduced from what it
once was you know there's all kinds of
non-human examples for instance the eyes
of blind cave fish for instance the the
wings of flightless birds like emus and
ostriches or the leg Spurs of snakes
like this boa constrictor these are
vestigial remnants of the fact that
their ancestors
we had legs in the past well let's but
let's focus on human examples of
vestigial structures let's first talk
about as in human embryo the human
embryo has gill slits or pharyngeal
arches as they're called now they're
vestigial they don't help the embryo
breathe like gills would help a fish
breathe but the fact that human embryos
have gills is a pretty clear indication
of our fish ancestors you know hundreds
of millions of years ago another good
example is your tailbone at the bottom
of this picture here you see the purple
small piece at the bottom labeled the
coccyx that's the scientific name for
the tailbone now for humans its
vestigial it doesn't help us for balance
but for other organisms it does you've
probably been to zoos and you've seen
monkeys using their tail for balance or
to wrap around a tree branch but for
humans its vestigial another good
example is the appendix and you know the
true function of the appendix we really
don't know in humans there are some
evidence that perhaps it will Harbor
good bacteria to help in the digestion
of our food but nonetheless vestigial
because its original function in humans
is lost in other organisms that have a
functional appendix it helps them to
digest plants and that's not its
function in humans another example would
be the third molar that some humans
eventually grow when they get older the
wisdom teeth you know for other
organisms this helps them grind plants
down again for humans it's vestigial the
heck some people you know we don't even
have room in our jaws anymore our jaws
have gotten smaller over the years we
don't even have room in our jaw for many
people to even have a wisdom tooth come
in you know without all kinds of pain
and problems where they actually have to
have the the tooth pulled by a dentist
another good example is the third eyelid
also called the the nictitating membrane
in humans it's vestigial but in other
organisms
keeps dust and dirt out you know it's
that pink in the corner of our eye you
know here's a great example of an in
another animal it helps to keep dust and
dirt out you know here's a bird now
watch as the picture changes you can see
a third eyelid beginning to come over
the eye and now you can see how this eye
has a translucent cover to it the third
eyelid and other animals is often
translucent and transparent though so
the organism can see through it yet
still keep dirt and dust out again this
is vestigial in humans but the fact that
we have a remnant of it is a link to our
past and so again we have all kinds of
evidence to indicate that we have
ancestral life in our in our long ago
past so the next topic I want to talk
about our homologous structures and
these are body parts with a remarkably
similar structure despite them
performing a different function you know
you look at these animals right here
they all live in different environments
the whales have adapted to life in the
oceans birds have adapted to flight and
flying through the air for example and
these four animals here are examples of
tetrapods tetrapods are animals that
have one two three four limbs to them
you know humans two arms two legs and
width we compare the four limb now the
word for limb just means like the front
limb for humans it's our arms dogs it's
the front legs and birds it's their
wings and in whales it's the front
flippers when we zoom in and compare the
bone structure and the muscles and the
ligaments and the tendons we see that a
remarkable similarity
yes the shape of the bones the size of
the bones are slightly altered because
it helps the organism in their
environment but the fact that these that
these structures here are so remarkably
similar to one another indicates that
probably some time ago in the long-ago
past they had a common ancestor
so the next topic i want to talk about
comes from the development of embryos
you know very different species actually
show a very remarkably similar pattern
of development here's an early embryo
drawing of a fish of a salamander a
tortoise a chicken a pig a cow a rabbit
in a human note that in their early
stage of development they are virtually
indistinguishable from one another now
as time goes by the different body plans
of a tortoise becomes more noticeable of
a pig becomes more noticeable and here
we have a later snapshot in their
development and then here we have you
know much later in their development and
now you can you really see the
difference between tortoises and pigs
but the fact that organisms follow a
very remarkable pattern of similarity
and how they develop again is a pretty
nice indication that at one time in our
evolutionary past
we had a common ancestor you know some
of the more compelling evidence of
evolution comes from biochemistry DNA
RNA proteins chromosomes you know for
example this piece of DNA through
transcription is used to make RNA and
then through translation a bunch of
amino acids are gathered and assembled
into a protein well this is true of all
life this is not just for humans not
just for mammals not just for animals
but all life here on earth
and so here we have the genetic code for
life on Earth again not just humans not
just mammals not just animals but all
life on Earth build their proteins in a
remarkably similar way again indicating
that life probably had a common origin a
common ancestor billions of years ago
well we also know that the more related
species are the more similar their DNA
and RNA their proteins the more similar
their biochemistry you know here we have
an elderly couple here well when they
were younger let's let's pretend they
had these two daughters and the daughter
on the Left married this man and the
daughter and the right married this man
and the daughter on the left over the
years had two children and the daughter
on the right had one child well what if
the daughter here asks the question who
do I have more DNA in common with my
male brother or my female cousin well
her dad says well the answer is you and
your brother you and your brother
because you and he have more recent
common ancestors only one generation has
passed since her and her brother had a
common ancestor but in regarding to the
cub with regard to the cousins you and
your cousins have a more distant common
ancestor your grandparents so the
farther back in time you go the less you
have in common with your DNA and your
genetics and your biochemistry
so let's relate that to humans and
chimpanzees and gorillas and orangutans
we've compared our DNA to that of a
chimp it turns out it's about 1.2
percent different compare that to a
gorilla humans and gorillas about 1.6
percent different in humans and chimps
about 3.1 percent difference in our
biochemistry this shows us that we have
a closer relationship with for instance
the chimpanzees we have a further ago
relationship with the orangutangs so
here we have a pathway leading to humans
and using the numbers from just a moment
to go since we have less in common with
orangutangs we know that they branched
off earlier than say gorillas because we
have more in common with gorillas than
orangutangs and therefore we even have
more in common with a chimp
notice how chimps and humans are really
side-by-side in this diagram because we
have more DNA in common we have a wasn't
as long ago that we had an ancestor with
chimps well you know what I want to do
right now I want to look at a protein
and compare it here is a protein called
cytochrome C and this protein is made
from a bunch of individual amino acids
in fact cytochrome C is made from 105
amino acids the a a in the circle means
amino acids and what we've done is we've
actually compared human cytochrome C to
that of fruit flies and bullfrogs and so
on and it turns out that human and fruit
fly differ in 24 of the 105 amino acids
but humans and bullfrogs we differ in 20
of those 105 humans and pigeons we
differ in 12 of the 105 humans versus
cows we differ in 10 out of the 105
amino-acids humans and rabbits we differ
in 9 of the 105 amino-acids humans and a
rhesus monkey we only differ in one of
the 105 amino acids and as far as
chimpanzees go when we compare our
cytochrome C to theirs they're identical
so here's some really good information
here that really shows you nicely how
closely we are related to chimpanzees
now this is only one protein of course
thousands of different proteins but in
this one example it nicely demonstrates
how remarkably similar we are to
chimpanzees and so what this again shows
us is that we probably had a very recent
ancestor with chimpanzees sometime in
our evolutionary past but it also shows
us that we had a ancestor with fruit
flies as well again 24 differences but a
hundred and five possibilities so again
that's 81 similarities between our
cytochrome C and fruit flies we actually
have a lot in common with fruit flies
but because time has passed a lot of
time has passed we've built up these 24
differences and so biochemistry has been
some of the most compelling evidence to
indicate that life has changed and
evolved over the years and the show that
life had a common ancestor okay so as we
wrap up you know if you're in my biology
class try these review questions here
and I'm happy to check your answer is
either before school one day or after
school so thanks for watching everyone